it's Skin Cancer Awareness Month and
today is melanoma Monday more people are
diagnosed with skin cancer each year
than all other cancers combined one in
five people will develop skin cancer by
the age of 70 and melanoma is the most
dangerous form it accounts for just 1%
of skin cancer cases but the majority of
deaths more than 91,000 people are
expected to be diagnosed with melanoma
this year dr. Elizabeth Hale is my
dermatologist she's a clinical associate
professor of dermatology at NYU Langone
Medical Center and also a paid
consultant for Coppertone good morning
good morning great to have you here last
year you diagnosed me with stage zero
melanoma what are some of the risk
factors for people so I'm so grateful
that we caught your melanoma early Nora
as you know you have many of the risk
factors you grew up in Texas where it
was very sunny you probably did not wear
enough sunscreen growing up you even
told me that you visited indoor tanning
beds before prom and things like that
and indoor tanning is a big risk factor
we see skin cancer and melanoma in all
skin types
but people with your coloring fair skin
light eyes who've spent a lot of time in
the Sun are at increased risk for sure I
thought one of the most interesting
things I learned from this too was that
tanning beds can increase your rate of
melanoma by 75% a lot of young women and
visit tanning beds it is a big problem
and it's dermatologists we're really
trying to help legislate this better
some states already do not allow indoor
tanning under the age of 18 and we're
really trying to work at it because
indoor tanning like you mentioned
directly increases your risk for
melanoma in fact last year a study came
out that melanoma is more linked to
tanning than smoking is to lung cancer
so it's a real risk and we're really
trying to educate our youths and our
adolescents to stay out of tanning beds
and to use more sunscreens you can have
used in adolescents no parent gets more
exercise than trying to put sunscreen so
how how much of a battle should you
engage in I mean is it super super
important to get it every day or give us
it how important it is for kids so it's
an excellent point it's super important
we know that blistering Sun burns during
childhood in fact five or more sunburns
at any time in our life del
our risk for melanoma so we really want
to treat children young and get them the
message that just like wearing a helmet
when they ride their bikes or when they
ski 4-h has a protect what matters most
campaign that's active right now and
it's really about in giving our kids the
power to engage in sunscreen themselves
so we're not the parents running around
trying to put it on and for my children
it's also important to teach them to
stay in the shade when possible and to
keep some protective clothing on hats
sunglasses all of these things can help
minimize our risk
I can also reapply right yes yeah to
reapply what's the best way to apply
sunscreen so we want to look for SPF 30
or higher
ideally sunscreens that say
broad-spectrum which mean they protect
from UVA and UVB rays ideally we'll put
it on 30 minutes before going outside
about the size of a shot glass to cover
your whole body and then like you
mentioned to reapply so if we're
sweating or if we're swimming we want to
reapply ideally every two hours but
that's really in the spring now that the
weather is finally nicer and in the
summer to your point about every day
when it's sunny outside I do put it on
my children every day even before school
in the winter I use it myself every day
for many reasons but on the kids it's a
struggle but definitely now that the
weather is warmer we should get them and
empower them to use sunscreen early well
we're so glad you're here this is a good
reminder is it's finally getting warm
outside and then the Sun has returned on
this melanoma Monday thank you as always
for your good care and advice activity
here thank mention thank you and you can
find more information about protecting
yourself from the sun by visiting our
website CBS this morning calm